Also, wie heißen Sie?
Haike, Schöne.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Voll- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Vornahmung bestabieren, wissen Sie nicht, wie Haike geschrieben wird?
Haike, Ha, E, I, C, K, E.
Wichtig?
Ohne C, nur K, E.
Nur K, E, okay. Und Schöne ist wie Schöne.
Genau.
Und Bende, E.
Genau. Also diese, okay.
Okay.
Genau.
Okay, Herr Schöne.
Und wie alt ist die Haike?
Haike ist grau.
Ja, okay.
Entschuldigung, Herr Schöne.
Kein Problem.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50, okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. Juni 1974.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 groß und 70 kg schwer.
Okay. Vielen Dank für die Angaben, Frau Schöne.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Mein, wie soll ich das sagen?
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass mein rechte Bein dick ist.
Rechte Bein dick geworden.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Beschwerden, Schmerzen habe ich jetzt seit 2, 3 Tagen.
Die Schwellung habe ich schon seit einer Woche.
Okay.
Also haben Sie Schwellung und auch Schmerzen?
Eine Woche.
Okay.
Wo verspüren Sie diese Schmerzen?
Obeschänkel oder Unterschenkel?
Oder Ganzesbein?
Ganzesbein, nicht ganzes, ganzesbein.
Ganzesbein, ja, okay.
Ist es mehr im Unterschenkel?
In der Warte?
Okay.
Wurden Sie verletzt oder hatten Sie einen Unfall oder ganz spontan auftreten?
Kein Unfall und keine Verletzung.
Okay.
Und Schutralen, diese Schmerzen, gehen Sie wohin aus oder nur in der Warte?
Überwiegend in der Warte.
Ohne Ausstrahlung kann man sagen.
Ja, halt im Bein, ne?
Im Unterschenkel.
Okay.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10,
0 keine Schmerzen, 10 sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht.
Wie können Sie einschliessen?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen, sind vergessen?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie stark sind meine Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10,
wenn 0 keine und 10 starken Schmerzen entsprechen?
Ich würde sagen, meine Schmerzen sind so bei 6.
6, okay.
Wie beschreiben, wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpfstechend, ziehend?
Das kann ich nicht beschreiben, ich weiß nur, dass es weh tut.
Okay.
Aber es ist eher, ich würde sagen, aber es ist eher ziehend, stechend.
Verspüren Sie Spannungsgefühl?
Ja, es ist spannend fair, ja.
Haben Sie bisher dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Schmerzmittel oder so?
Ich habe jetzt kein Schmerzmittel genommen.
Können Sie bis zum Ende dieses Geschipel, diese Schmerzen aushalten
oder möchten Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Das ist aber so lieb von Ihnen, dass Sie fragen.
Ich wäre Ihnen sehr dankbar, wenn Sie mir etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben würden.
Ja, okay.
Frau Schöne, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Erst mal einen Zugang legen
und dann ein Schmerzmittel über die Gefäße geben.
Gefäße, nicht Gefäße.
Okay, aber davor muss ich fragen,
haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente allergieren?
Ich habe keine allergieren.
Ein Antibiotikum, Moment.
Okay, noch eine Medikamente.
Sonst sind keine Schmerzmittel allergieren?
Nein, nicht das ich küsste, bis jetzt nicht.
Okay, dann haben Sie keine Medikamente eingenommen
und noch eine Frage,
ist es möglich, dass Sie aktuell schwanger sind
oder sind Sie schon im Wegsverlager?
Ich bin 50, ich bin nicht mehr schwanger.
Okay, dann, okay.
Wir können Schmerzmittel geben.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Auslöser bemerkt für diese Schmerzen und Schmelung?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Trauma haben Sie nicht gesagt,
es könnte sehr lange laufen sein?
Laufen?
Laufen oder sitzen könnte sein.
Eine lange Reise zum Beispiel,
in der letzten Zeit haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht?
Zeit, in der letzten Zeit.
Eine lange Reise.
Also sagen wir mal so,
es tut sowohl im Liegen weh
als auch wenn ich laufe, tut es weh.
Wenn ich trete, tut es auch weh, das Spanns wär.
Nein, eine lange Reise habe ich nicht gemacht.
Okay, aber beim Laufen
verstärken sich die Schmerzen?
Es ändert sich nicht,
es tut im Liegen genauso weh wie wenn ich laufe.
Okay, im Liegen und beim Laufen.
Genau, es ist ein Dauerschmerz.
Haben Sie andere Verstärkte oder andere Faktoren bemerkt?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel Hochlagerung verbessert
oder verstärkt ihre Schmerzen.
Ich habe es nicht hochgelagert,
aber es hat nicht den Schmerz verändert.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam oder plötzlich auch getreten?
Das habe ich ja gesagt.
Vor zwei Tagen haben Sie angefangen.
Seitdem ist es ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Doch seit vor zwei Tagen hat es angefangen.
Es ist langsam mehr geworden.
Es ist ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Langsam, aber immer so genommen.
Ich habe Ihnen gesagt,
dass ich vor einer Woche
vor zwei Tagen die Schmerzen hatte.
Heute habe ich auch Luftnoten.
Das habe ich vergessen zu sagen.
Luftnot haben Sie?
Heute ist diese...
Ich habe nicht so gut Luft bekommen.
Was meinen Sie?
Über Zusammenhang Luftnot
und diese Beinschwählung und Schmerzen fragen Sie.
Ja, meinen Sie, dass es einfach psychisch ist,
dass ich jetzt Luftnot habe?
Wir können nicht direkt psychisch sagen.
Es muss erst mal herausfinden.
Deswegen werde ich dieses...
Wir müssen es erst mal herausfinden.
Deswegen werde ich dieses Geschick brief unterbrechen.
Dann werde ich Ihre Vitalparameter
von meinen Kollegen gemessen.
Damit meinte ich Blutdruck.
Herzatemfragen.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Ich meinte jetzt, sie meinen es jetzt.
Damit meine ich, ja?
Danke, danke.
Das ist sehr liebfroh Ihnen.
Und dann bekommen Sie Sauerstoff über die Nase.
Damit können wir unseres Gespräch fortführen können.
Unser Gespräch,
nicht unseres Gespräch,
sondern damit können wir Unser Gespräch.
damit können wir unserer Gespräch, das Gespräch weiterführen.
Und damit können wir das Gespräch weiterführen.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie zusätzlich Überwärmung oder Haus an der Betroffenenstelle?
Im Gesicht?
Nein, in der Wade an der Betroffenenstelle.
Ah, in der Wade.
Ja, im rechten Bein.
Es ist nicht rot.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht sehr warm.
Es ist gleich.
Okay, Überwärmung auch nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Glasehaut.
Was meinen Sie?
Glanzahaut.
Was heißt Glanzahaut?
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe Sie nicht.
Glanzahaut ist sehr, wie kann ich erklären, keine Ahnung,
an die Dönerhaut zum Beispiel.
Ah, die Haut glänzt oder was?
Glänzt, ja.
Glänzende Haut meinen Sie?
Ich glaube nicht.
Gläsernahaut oder was meinen Sie?
Glänzende Haut, okay, glänzende Haut.
Nein, nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste, aber ich kann das auch Ihnen nicht genau sagen.
Ich bin doch kein Arzt.
Okay, natürlich, ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich gucke selbst, okay.
Und haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Hier?
Ja, Brustschmerzen, irgendwo, alle Brustkorb könnte sein.
Nein, nein, aber es ist bestimmt psychisch,
oder ich habe das Gefühl, ich bekomme keine Luft.
Ja, machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Erst mal, wir sollen untersuchen.
Alle mögliche Ursachen sollen wir überprüfen.
Werden wir überprüfen, dann, wenn keine Ursache finden,
können wir psychische sagen.
Also, weil ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich nicht so gut Luft bekomme.
Es geht nicht rein, wissen Sie?
Und nach der Sauerstoffgabe fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, es ist jetzt besser geworden.
Okay, dann können wir weitermachen.
Haben Sie den Krebel oder den Taupatsgefühl im rechten Bein?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, und fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, die Schwester hat eben Temperatur gemessen.
Ich habe keinen Fieber.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und wie ist der Appetit?
Ein Appetit kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich habe halt heute etwas Luftnot und deswegen habe ich keinen Appetit,
weil ich mich nicht so gut fühle.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Er leider zugenommen, ja.
Wie viele Kilos haben Sie zugenommen?
2-3 Kilo vielleicht.
Ich esse aber auch gerne.
Ich habe einen sehr guten Appetit.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie das.
Und in welchen Zeitrop haben Sie zugenommen?
Können Sie etwas sagen?
Kann ich gar nicht genau sagen.
Ich wollte Ihnen damit nur sagen,
dass ich eher zugenommen habe als abgenommen.
Okay, dann.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen?
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, ich habe so alle 2 Tage Stuhlgang.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Probleme.
Da habe ich so ein bisschen Verstopfung.
Das habe ich aber schon immer gehabt.
Das ist so bei mir.
Und Wasserlassen, was meinen Sie mit Wasserlassen?
Ich kann ganz normal Wasserlassen.
Okay, haben Sie Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Weniger Wasserlassen und keine.
Immer gebörnlich.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl gehabt,
die letzten 2 Tage, dass ich nachts ein bisschen mehr raus muss.
Okay, in der letzten Zeit.
War Ihnen übel?
Nein, keine Übelkeit.
Haben Sie erbrochen in der letzten Zeit?
Nein.
Und wo stehen Sie?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, sowieso ein Reiz im Halb.
Ich habe das Gefühl.
Ist das neu mit der Luftnot?
Entschuldigung.
Ist dieser Husten neu mit der Luftnot?
Ja, ich kann das damit zusammen zusammen.
Vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, okay.
Was ist das für eine gute Zeit?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich in der letzten Zeit gut in der letzten Zeit wegen dieser Beschwerde bin.
Eigentlich habe ich letzte Nacht, ging es eigentlich noch.
Aber seit heute Morgen habe ich die Luftnot.
Eigentlich habe ich die letzten 2 Tage eigentlich gut geschlafen.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen.
Leiden Sie an dauerhaften Erkrankungen, Frau Schöne.
Ich habe zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit.
Oder erhöhte Blutfetwerte könnte sein.
Oder andere Blutgerinnungsprobleme.
Der Arzt hat gesagt, ich muss abnehmen und dass mein Cholesterinspiegel etwas erhöht ist.
Seit wann?
Aber ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Das war vor 3 Monaten beim Arzt, beim Checkup ist das rausgekommen.
Okay.
Noch andere Krankheiten haben Sie?
Keine.
Nein, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich Ihnen das erzählt habe, ob das wichtig ist.
Sie haben mich ja nicht gefragt, ob ich schon mal operiert worden bin.
Sie haben mich nicht gefragt.
Aber ich habe ja jetzt ganz lange im Krankenhaus gelegen vor 3 Wochen.
Weil ich operiert worden bin an der Hüfte.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Polerkrankungen.
Die Hüfte ist operiert worden.
Ich zähle das als dauerhafte Erkrankung.
Da war ich ganz lange im Krankenhaus.
Welche Operation wurde Ihnen durchgeführt?
Die Hüfte ist kaputt gegangen, weil ich das aber schon lange her.
Das musste gemacht werden, das haben wir immer aufgeschoben.
Und jetzt habe ich mich vor 3 Wochen operieren lassen.
Es gab ein paar Komplikationen und ich musste länger im Krankenhaus legen.
Das hat sich infiziert, die Wunde und so weiter.
Okay, Wunde infiziert und bekommen haben Sie Protease bekommen?
Ja, eine Hüfte bekommen und dann wegen Wunde.
Ja, irgendwas war da.
Auf jeden Fall musste ich länger leben, genau.
Wurde Ihnen gesagt, dass Sie Blutgerinnungsprobleme hatten?
Nein.
Ich hatte keine Gerinnungsprobleme.
Ich hatte nur ein bisschen Schmerz an der Hüfte.
Ich habe Schmerzen mitgekriegt und Antibiotikum gekriegt.
Und eine Bauchspritze habe ich gekriegt.
Bauchspitze für die Blutgerinnung haben Sie bekommen?
Ich weiß nicht, warum man das gibt.
Ich habe eine Bauchspritze gekriegt, jeden Tag im Krankenhaus.
Okay.
Dann welche Medikamente nehmen Sie, regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Keine Medikamente.
Ich habe bis vor einer Woche noch die Bauchspritze weitergenommen.
Da hat der Arzt gesagt, das ist wichtig.
Weil ich operiert worden bin, muss ich das noch einnehmen.
Ich weiß nicht, wofür das war.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist für die Vorbeugung von einer Verstopfung in der Gefäße.
In den Gefäße?
Ah, ja, so etwas hat der Arzt auch gesagt.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt.
Und zu einer Woche habe ich das abgesetzt?
Selbst abgesetzt.
Ich sollte das absetzen.
Der Arzt hat gesagt, vor einer Woche darf ich das absetzen.
Was anderes habe ich nicht eingenommen.
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme noch Ibuprofen ein, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Aber das ist jetzt auch schon besser geworden.
Ich muss das nicht mehr regelmäßig einnehmen.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie ein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie Penicillin-Allergie haben.
Ansonsten haben Sie andere Allergien.
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Und Verzweiligkeiten haben Sie?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Äußert sich.
Nicht äußert sich die Allergie.
Ich habe das als Kind schon sehr stark reagiert.
Ich habe meine Eltern gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert, wenn ich das einnehmen würde.
Okay, danke.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Wogegen?
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten.
Auf Briechung, Impfungen.
Natürlich Corona.
Covid-19?
Ja.
Covid-19 bin ich zweimal geimpft.
Und die Kinderimpfung ist abgeschlossen.
Das war schon früher.
Eine Aufrischimpfung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann meine letzte Aufrischimpfung war.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit,
waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten.
Frau Schöne.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein.
Und haben Sie früher geraucht?
Das ist sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Das ist eine routimäßige Frage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, das freut mich.
Regelmäßig.
Ich sehe uns jetzt ein bisschen schwer.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familiengeschichte sprechen.
Sprächen.
Haben Sie eine gute Frage?
Nein.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche dauerhafte Erkrankungen?
Meine Eltern sind gestorben.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Woran sind Sie verstorben?
Meine Mutter hatte Krebs.
Welche Krebs?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Meine Mutter ist gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist natürlich verstorben.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich glaube, mein Vater hatte Bluthochdruck.
Okay.
Ich habe alles notiert.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress im Leben?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin noch zu Hause.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Mein Mann ist da.
Wir haben keine Probleme.
Das freut mich sehr.
Die letzte Frage.
Ich habe keine Krampfadern.
Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein.
Ich habe eine Urlaub gebucht.
Wir wollten nach Dubai fliegen.
Ich möchte gerne nach Dubai fliegen.
Ich muss gesund werden.
Das wäre schön.
Aber erst mal müssen wir unseren Verdacht bestätigen.
Erst mal müssen wir.
Nicht wir müssen.
Erst mal müssen wir meinen Verdacht bestätigen.
Wir sind nicht zu oft.
Wir sind sehr Czech.
Wenn man diese Krankheit behandelt.
Nach Ihren Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht haben.
Wir müssen 1.
Wir haben unseren Verdacht bestätigen.
Erricane machen.
Es soll aber meinen Verdacht bestätigen.
Erst mal müssen wir einen Verdacht bestätigen.
Was denken Sie, Frau Doktor, was ich habe? Ist das alles psychisch mit der Luft?
Ist das alles psychisch? Weil ich Angst habe?
Ja, nein, es ist so, wie du etwas genauer sagen kannst.
Aber ich kann sagen, erst mal nein. Sie können eine Verstüpfung in Beinwähne,
Beingefeste haben. Ja, das scheint so. Deswegen würde ich gerne Sie erst mal schnell
möglichst körperlich untersuchen.
Muss ich bleiben oder kann ich jetzt nach Hause gehen?
Ich könnte jetzt nicht genauer sagen, nach allen Ergebnissen kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen,
ob Sie bei uns bleiben oder nach Hause gehen dürfen.
Das heißt, Sie werden jetzt alle Untersuchungen ambulant durchführen, nicht stationär?
Ja, es scheint so, dass Sie ein paar Tage bei uns bleiben müssen.
Das heißt, ich muss doch stationär aufgenommen werden?
Ja, jetzt dachte ich so, aber erst mal allen Ergebnissen brauche ich, dann muss ich mit meinem Operatür.
Dann muss ich, dann muss ich nicht.
Dann muss ich mit meinem Operatür.
Nur wenn der Satz mit ich beginnt, wenn man mit dann beginnt, dann muss ich.
Okay.
Dann muss ich mit meinem Operatür.
Alles klar, dann machen Sie sich das bitte, weil ich muss doch du beifliegen.
Ja, wie viele Müssen Sie diesen Urlaub ein bisschen verschieben?
Das geht nicht. Ich kriege das Geld nicht zurück.
Ich habe einen billigen Flug gebucht, es geht nicht. Das sind 3000 Euro, die fliegen weg.
Ja, natürlich ist der Urlaub wichtig für Sie, aber Ihre Gesundheit ist wichtiger.
Ja, das will ich doch gar nicht hören tun Ihnen. Sie sollen mir bitte einfach helfen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, Sie sind die Ärzte, helfen Sie mir. Ich muss nach Dubai fliegen.
Aber das dauert ein bisschen lange.
Meine manche Heilungen können lange Zeit dauern.
Sie müssen ein paar Monate vielleicht lange Reise...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das kommt gar nicht in Frage ein paar Monate.
Ich gebe Ihnen drei Tage und dann will ich nach Hause.
Es könnte lebensbedrohliche Komplikationen auftreten.
Warum bin ich hier? Deswegen sind Sie da und deswegen sollen Sie mich behandeln.
Ich möchte in drei Tagen wieder nach Hause und ich möchte gerne gesund nach Hause.
Und ich möchte nach Dubai fliegen.
Und jetzt können Sie anfangen mit Ihrer Untersuchung.
Okay, ja, ich fange an und dann erst mal ernstige Behandlungen werden wir durchführen.
Später können wir noch mal darüber sprechen.
Danke. Tut mir leid, ich wollte ja gar nicht laut werden.
Danke schön.
Zunächst möchte ich unsere Kollegen applaudieren.
Sie waren gut, ne? Sie hat das gut gemacht.
Ich meine, ich meine, nachdem sie eine gute Assimilation gemacht hat.
Ja, Sie haben es gut gemacht. Sie hat das richtig gut gemacht.
Ich habe gedacht, Sie wollen meine Schauspielerei applaudieren.
Ich habe mit dem Küchen schon sehr gefreut.
Am besten her.
Ja, sag ich doch, am allerbesten.
Das war wirklich sehr gut. Das war wirklich sehr gut.
Wir können ja erst, das Obert war sehr gut wirklich.
Ja, haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch eine Frage.
Ich glaube nicht, ne?
Ich habe nur Symptome gefragt, die Sie fragen mussten.
Der Patient hat eine Angstzustand und deswegen hat er eine Perleme, was bedeutet?
Schwitzen?
Schwitzen, Kalsschweiß?
Kalsschweiß usw.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt, die Sie haben.
Ja, ich finde auch, das hat Sie gekauft.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ich habe nicht gefragt, vorherriger.
Achso, was Sie hätten noch fragen sollen, ist, ne?
Weil Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie hat den Verdacht auf eine TVT mit LAE.
Die OP hat Sie vergessen zu fragen, ob ich noch Operation hatte und ob ich schon mal Krebs hatte.
Krebs, ja.
Ja, erst mal bei der aktuellen Beschwerde habe ich viele Zeit.
Ja, ja, alles gut. Ich sage ja nur, das war sehr gut.
Aber in der Prüfung, in der Simulation ist alles sehr schwer, aber Sie haben das super gemacht wirklich.
Aber man hätte halt noch, wenn man den Verdacht hat, dann immobilisieren immer im Kopf haben und Immobilisationen.
Was ist Immobilisation? OP ist Immobilisation. Reise ist Immobilisation. Und bösartige Erkrankungen.
Ja.
Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch?
Wenn unsere Kollegen keine Fragen haben, können wir erst das anfangen.
Ja.
Ich muss nach Frankreich. Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie Haarausfall im Ihren Bein bemerkt? Haarausfall.
Haarausfall im Bein nicht? Auf dem Bein?
Oder am Bein?
Auf dem Bein und oder am Bein? Ich stammte dir, was sagt man Haarausfall auf den Bein an bemerkt, oder?
An den Beinen.
Am Bein oder an den Beinen? Und es geht um das rechte Bein, ne? Wie kommen Sie auf Haarausfall?
Pile Schaufenster-Krankheit könnte es sein.
Das ist die Krankheit?
Schaufenster-Pile-Krankheit.
Ich habe auch keine Haarausfall bemerkt.
Müssten Sie beim Laufen Pause machen oder stehen bleiben, während des Laufen stehen bleiben?
Nein. Nein. Nein. Nein. Also Sie meinen, ob das besser wird, wenn ich stehenbleibe, mein Sie?
Beim Laufen.
Ja, ich bin nicht so viel gelaufen, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, ich habe mich jetzt geschont.
Und das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass ich dann stehenbleibe, weil ich aber auch nicht viel gelaufen bin. Ich bin keine 100 Meter gelaufen.
100 Meter. Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ja, danke.
Können Sie anfangen? Präzik.
Ja.
Ja, schönen Tag, liebe Oberärztin. Ich habe heute mit einer neuen Patientin das Anamnese-Geschiebrecht geführt und würde gerne Ihnen den Fall vorstellen. Haben Sie dafür kurze Zeit?
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Haike Schöne. Frau Schöne sei 50 Jahre alt, am 28.6.1975 geboren.
Dann sagt man wirklich, sei 50 Jahre alt oder ist 50 Jahre alt? Ist, ne?
Ja, okay.
Sei ist das so? Es ist egal. Ist mir egal. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Prüfung, wie die Prüfung ist.
Man müsste ja immer diese…
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Prüfung ist, aber ich muss die Prüfung in der Prüfung schiprieren.
Okay.
Ölren Sie mich?
Ola, gitt ihr? Ja.
Hallo? Ja, komm, komm.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und Frau Schöne ist 50 Jahre alt, am 65.70 kg schwer.
Frau Schöne, ich trete Sie heute, wegen seit einer Woche, seit zwei bis drei Tagen bestehende, langsam aufgetretene, dauerhafter und progrediente,
sowie rechtseitiger unterchenke Schmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung bei uns vor.
Sie ordnet Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala bei sechs von zehn ein.
Und…
Statt? Statt? Ja.
Sie stellte sich alles super, perfekter Satz, sowie rechtseitiger Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen und rechtzeitig gehören nicht zusammen, deswegen kann man nicht sowie rechtseitiger Schmerzen.
Man kann sagen, wegen Schwellung sowie Spannungsgefühl, sowie, wenn man diese Schmerzen dasselbe aufzählt, kann man dann am Ende sagen,
sowie, aber sowie rechtzeitig ist nicht dasselbe.
Einfach nur rechtzeitiger Schmerzen vor, sowie weg.
Okay, dann mache ich so.
Und bei der Patienten seien keine Auslöser oder keine Auslöser, Verstärke oder Linderefaktoren aufgefallen?
Ja, Patientin, nicht bei der Patientin, sondern der Patientin sind keine aufgefallen. Okay.
Okay, ohne bei.
Darüber hinaus leidet die Patienten als Begleitzentome unter Odeeme und akut auch getretener Luftnud.
Luftnud geht auch alles so, dass sie nicht nud.
Und die Fragen nach Rötung, Überwärmung, Torakalgie, Hautveränderungen, Hyperesthesie, Paresthesie wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative an Amnesie zeigt 2 bis 3 kg Gewichtsunahme in der letzten Zeit.
Zeit.
Und dann die düstener Bedingte in Appetenz und langsamer Obstipation und auch in der letzten Zeit nächtliche Wasserlassen.
Nächtliches Wasserlassen.
Das Wasserlassen.
Ja, und Reizkusten.
Reizkusten.
Ja.
Die anderen vegetative an amnesische Angaben sind unauffällig.
Ausguckvor Erkrankungen seien bei der Patientin Hyperpolesteroid, seit 3 Monaten, die durch Diät behandelt worden seien.
Hat sie gesagt, dass sie Diät gemacht hat? Nein.
Ja, Diät empfohlen wurde, aber sie...
Hat sie auch nicht empfohlen der Arzt? Hab ich nicht gesagt?
Doch, Diät empfohlen?
Nein. Hab ich gesagt, hab ich nicht gesagt? Nein.
Ist aber auch egal, Entschuldigung. Ich muss immer unterbrechen und sie aus dem Konzept bringen, damit das...
Okay, alles klar. Ich bin Oberärztin, ich darf das.
Und als Voroperationen nannte die Patienten Hüftgelenk, total endoprothese.
Und nach der Operation habe die Patienten...
Wann war denn die Operation? Hab ich nicht gefragt.
Vor einem Monat?
Vor 3 Wochen hat sie gesagt, 3 Wochen hatte sie die OP.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Hat sie gesagt, vor 3 Wochen war die OP, das ist ja wichtig.
Der zeitliche Zusammenhang ist ja wichtig. Das müssen Sie sagen, deswegen.
Ja, okay. Vor 3 Wochen, nach der Operation, habe die Patienten Tromboemboli-Profilaxi bekommen.
Und bis vor einer Woche, habe sie geschübt Britz.
Sehr gut.
Und die Medikamente an Amnesty ergab Noah, die Einnahme von Ibuprofen bei Bedarf.
Bei der Patienten sei Penicillin allergie bekannt, die sich anapylaktische Schock äußere oder unbekannte äußere...
Sie hatten eine schwere Reaktion als Kind gehabt, deswegen meidet sie Penicillin.
An Amnesty hat sie eine schwere Reaktion gehabt, an die sie sich aber nicht erinnern kann als Kind.
Und seitdem meidet sie Penicillin, kann man sagen.
War ja auch so, ne?
Okay.
Der im Status sei voruständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19.
Impfung zweimal. Die Aufrichtung Impfungen seien von der Patienten unbekannt.
Die Reise an Amnesty sei unauffällig.
Der Drogenkonsum, Alkohol und Rauchen, Nikotinkonsum wurden verneint.
Ich habe der Vater an Arteriagipartoni und Diabetes Melitus gelitten und sei altersbedingt ursachen verstorben.
Ursache weglassen, das war schon sehr gut.
Sei altersbedingt verstorben. Super.
Okay, Ursache nicht mehr.
Und die Mutter leide an einem Karzinom, die von der Patienten unbekannt sei.
Die der Patientin nicht bekannt sei.
Nicht bekannt sei.
Oder diese sei der Patientin unbekannt.
Was für ein Karzinom das ist, ne?
Okay.
Für eine schöne sei ein Zellkind, herheiratet, Hausrafen, Beruf, Habit, keine Kinder.
Sehr gut. Super aufgezählt.
Nach diesen an Amnestischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf TVT, Tiefe, Beine, Beine, Wenne, Bein, Wennen, Trombose.
Tief, Bein, Wennen, Trombose.
Okay.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Tief, Bein, Wennen, Trombose.
Und aus Differenzialdiagnose kommen periferische arteriale Verschlusskrankheit.
Wirklich, kommt das in Frage?
Wie sieht denn das der Bein von der Patientin aus?
Wie hat es dir das denn beschrieben?
Sie haben gesagt geschwollen Badenschmerzen.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob das linke Bein auch geschwollen ist?
Oder ist es nur das rechte Bein geschwollen?
Nur rechte Bein hat.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob das Bein kalt oder kalt ist?
Nicht gefragt, nur...
Okay.
Aber ich sage Ihnen, das Bein ist nicht kalt.
Ich sage Ihnen einfach jetzt mal.
Haben Sie mal die Pulse getastet?
Noch nicht, aber bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich palpieren.
Das haben Sie jetzt schon gemacht.
Sie haben die körperlichen Untersuchung schon gemacht.
Haben Sie die Pulse getastet?
Ja, natürlich haben Sie die Pulse getastet.
Und die waren tastbar, ne?
Ja, also kann das keine PAVK sein.
Was kann es denn sonst sein für Differenzialdiagnose?
Eine einseitige Beinschwellung?
Erzipel oder...
Ein Beispiel, entzündlich, ne?
Was noch?
Ein Bein?
Es kommt nur eine Frage noch, was wirklich sein könnte.
Posttrombozidius-Syndrom.
Posttrombozidius-Syndrom, da ist immer einseitige Schwellung dann, ne?
Weil die Thrombose betrifft ja immer nur ein Bein.
Also posttrombozidius-Syndrom,
Baritzen haben Sie schon gefragt, das könnte vielleicht auch sein,
aber sehr selten, ja?
Und Proteinorie kommt auch nicht in Frage.
Das würde eher wohl sein, beidseits, ne?
Oder Trauma wäre auch einseitig, wenn es ein Trauma gewesen ist.
Das haben Sie aber alles gefragt, ne?
Trauma ist nicht vorausgegangen.
Genau, und PAVK ist eher unwahrscheinlich,
weil PAVK macht keine Schwellung, ne?
Eigentlich einseitige.
Aber wir sollen auch als Differenzialdiagnose
alle mögliche Ursachen erst mal...
Sehr gut, das war super.
Ich bin Oberärztin, ich darf trotzdem fragen.
Ich darf Schimpfen immer.
Sehr gut.
Dann soll fragen, was ich dagegen spreche.
Was dagegen spreche.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
erst mal werde ich die Vitalparameter messen.
Dann bei der Inspektion werde ich
die Betroffenenstelle inspecieren.
Schwellung und Hautveränderungen
haben Sie alles schon gemacht, ne?
Sie haben die Hautveränderungen angeguckt, genau.
Das haben Sie auch alles gefragt.
Labordiagnostisch werde ich
Entzündungparameter, Bulldogbild und
Dedimmer-Gerinnungparameter
werde ich beurteilen.
Was noch?
Ein Wert ist noch wichtig, das müssen Sie bei Ihr machen.
Auch wenn das eine einseitige Schwellung ist,
kann trotzdem auch eine kardiale Decompensation rennen.
Das müssen Sie auch noch sagen,
bei der Differenzialdiagnose.
Rechtserzdecompensation, gerade bei der Lungenembolie.
Es kann ja auch herzsinnend insuffizient sein.
Vor allen Dingen aber rechtserzinsuffizient.
Es macht zwar keine einseitige Beinschwellung,
aber es gibt ja alles auf dieser Welt.
Das eine Bein dicker war als das andere.
Das kann ja auch sein.
Das ist ein sehr guter Wert.
Und als Apparativgeregnostik?
Sie müssen noch einen Wert machen.
Warum?
Weil es Luftnoten gibt.
Wegen der Lungenembolie?
Haben Sie den Verdacht, dass es eine Lungenembolie sein könnte?
Ja, sehr gut.
Welchen Wert müssen Sie noch machen?
Welcher Wert ist ganz wichtig bei Lungenembolie?
Der Dimmer ist wichtig?
Der Dimmer ist allgemein wichtig.
Pro BNP bei der Lungenembolie.
Welche Werte sagen aus über die
Mortalitätsrisiko in den nächsten Tagen?
Welche Werte?
Nur das Pro BNP.
Und welche noch?
Das sind diese Werte, die ganz wichtig sind.
Prognose, was Aussagen.
Prognostische Aussage.
Entschuldigung, das wollte ich sagen.
Pro BNP und Pro BNP.
Und Troponin.
Das sind die Werte, die prognostische Aussagen machen.
Lesen Sie erst mal nach.
Die sagen prognostisch, wie der Verlauf ist.
Wenn die hoch sind, ist das ein Hinweis dafür,
dass sie es nicht richtig machen.
Sie haben die Anamnese super gemacht.
Die körpahlige Untersuchung war nicht schlecht.
Die Labur ist auch okay.
Sie haben einen wichtigen Wert pro BNP und Troponin vergesst.
Und was machen Sie noch?
Diagnostik?
Ich werde eine Duplix-Sonografie durchführen.
Eine Plasone-Grafie der Beine.
Und die Arteriografie?
Nein, die Arteriografie.
Wenn der Patient auf der Trage liegt,
im Ultraschallraum,
und Sie machen den Bein,
und Sie haben den Verlauf auf eine lunge,
dann müssen Sie die noch machen.
Ultraschallgerät ist doch schon in der Hand.
Immer zusammen.
Sie machen einen Echo-Gardiogramm.
Ich werde rechtsherz...
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Warum?
Das ist ein indirekter Hinweis für eine Lungenembolie.
Manche Patienten, wenn sie ein hohes Kreatinien haben
und sie nicht die Möglichkeit im Haus haben,
außer einen CT zum Beispiel, eine Lungenzintigraphie zu machen,
wenn sie Kontrastmittel geben müsste,
und die Kreatinien sind sehr hoch, sie können es nicht machen.
Dann bleibt Ihnen nur als Mittel der Wahl das Echo-Gardiogramm.
Stehen Sie? Also ist das wichtig.
Wenn Sie Doppler machen, machen Sie gleich den Echo mit.
Und um die Lungenembolie zu bestätigen,
Computer-Tomographie mit Kontrastmittel...
Sehr gut. CT-Angiografie.
Ja, sehr gut.
Nicht bestätig, verdacht.
Ja, um das zu bestätigen, um den Verdacht zu bestätigen.
Das ist schon richtig.
Also wenn Sie den Verdacht haben, dass eine Lungenembolie ist,
bestätigen Sie Standard, Goldstandard.
Der Diagnose bei Lungenembolie ist immer noch CT-Angiografie.
Ja, okay.
Und dann bei der Therapie.
Erst mal unbedingt stationär aufnehmen.
Verdeckstationär aufnehmen.
Hochlagerung, Schonung, Kühlung werde ich empfehlen.
Es kommt darauf an.
Schonung, Kühlung. Warum schonen Sie Sie?
Wegen der Thrombose?
Oder wegen der Lungenembolie?
Schonung, erstmal für die Schmerzen.
Nein, schonen,
körperliche Schonung
und Bettruhe nur wegen der Lungenembolie.
Nicht wegen der Thrombose.
Okay.
Wann darf sie aufstehen mit der Thrombose?
Darf auch aufstehen, okay.
Nein, ich will wissen, wann darf sie aufstregen mit der Thrombose?
Sobald die Beine gewickelt sind,
müssen die Beine gewickelt sein, richtig?
Also Sie müssen das Bein richtig wickeln lassen.
Stramm, Kompressionsstrumpfe bestellen,
wickeln das Bein und dann darf sie aufstehen.
Aber sie darf ja eine Lungenembolie nicht aufstehen.
Okay.
Warum? Weil sie Rechtsheitsbelastung hat.
Und wissen Sie, was wir noch vergessen haben?
Da war einer von Ihren Kollegen daran gedacht,
eine Blutgasanalyse, das hätten wir auch machen können.
Ich habe das aber auch vergessen, alles gut.
Ich habe in der Prüfung auch alles vergessen, macht nichts.
Das müssen wir uns merken.
Da hat einer uns daran erinnert, die haben ja so typische gekreuzte Gase.
CO2 ist niedrig und CO2 ist erhöht, meine ich,
und Sauerstoffsättigung, also PO2, Sauerstoff-Patialdruck
ist sehr niedrig, das sind immer so gekreuzte Gase.
Das ist schon gut, was er gesagt hat.
Eine BGA muss man immer machen, Nathalie.
Okay.
Hab ich auch vergessen, ist aber nicht schlimm.
Alles andere war sehr gut.
Was ist das für eine kompressionsströmung?
Ich bedrohle erst mal wegen der Rechtsheitsbelastung.
Was noch?
Heparinisierung ist die causale Therapie.
Heparinisierung, nicht Heparinisierung gibt es nicht.
Heparinisierung.
Oder Anticoagulation, sagen Sie Anticoagulation.
Okay.
Anticoagulation.
Mit Heparin.
Genau, sehr gut.
Was ist das?
Intravenös.
Sie wollen im Intravenös systemisch heparinilisieren.
Systemische Anticoagulation, Sie wollen es IV geben.
Können Sie das auch?
Können Sie das auch Subkutan geben?
Geht das?
Ja.
Gewicht adaptiert geht das, aber Sie müssen gucken,
dass Dinierenwerte nicht so stark erhöht sind.
Dann können Sie auch relativ rasch Anticoagulation einleiten.
Aber das ist alles, glaube ich, fachspezifisch.
Das muss Sie alles nicht wissen.
Subkutan, Coagulation, gelb gut.
genug, Anticoagulation ist komisch.
Super, das war wirklich gut.
Bravo.